kids of red pill we have Rebecca and Ali
on here those are the home girls Janelle
um like but there's not that many women
in this space
um what like you said that it it enables
men to understand female nature so as a
woman what don't men understand about
women
oh my God you see what I'm saying here
you're like all right so it helps you
understand women it's kind of help us
understand women okay I mean I would I
would say first and foremost just it's
just especially doing the show it's just
crazy how much girls like cap and I just
think a lot of people for cap for 30 and
overcrowd that means a lot okay
um and like I also think it's important
to understand like that women are
hypergamous like I think that's
important and the things that you need
to do to be attractive to women like and
I don't give dating advice like that's
not my thing you know but I think it's
important that men understand that you
know women like they don't like nice
guys they tend to like guys that have a
backbone like that sort of thing yeah
and you don't think that guys know that
now a lot of times not when they're
younger when they get older I feel like
most guys figure it out but when they're
younger well I feel like that most men
have to go through some [ __ ] you have to
go through some heartbreak you got to go
through some struggles even yesterday
the guy on the show she's a unicorn yeah
like I've met so many guys like that
let's get real hey
that's only half the story though Pearl
he just got out of a divorce yeah so I
think once you get a divorce and you
have two kids I think you recognize that
women aren't sugar and sweet and
everything nice he meets a new girl and
even if she's a unicorn I think he
recognizes all right I also love my wife
when I married her 10 years ago okay but
go deeper with women okay Beyond
understanding that you can't just be Mr
Nice Guy and uh women aren't sugar and
spice and everything nice go deeper like
pretend it's not even us here and you're
you're just like in the women's locker
room and you're talking locker room talk
for the women like what are what are
those conversations that are being said
because you have no problem calling out
women and feminists so for the men out
there like give us a little glimpse into
like what it's really like what they're
saying like hypergamous
tell a story I love anecdotes I love
stories there is a girl in college like
girl next door right I promise you like
she was like cute sweet quiet you never
know and I've told the story a lot of my
podcast but basically she dates a guy
freshman year right this guy she was
obsessed with dates and for a month he
cheats on her it ends whatever right
four years later she's dating another
guy
this guy bought her a house
a house
a house
and literally
um I was at a party and literally she
cheated with the guy from freshman year
in the bathroom at the party that the
other guy was at and it's like guys
don't even think girls are like capable
of this stuff and like they would never
expect that from her and like sometimes
it's just like the girls that you would
not expect yeah but and you know I'm not
saying every girl's gonna do that I'm
not saying that's 100 of women but like
sometimes I think it's important where
we have spaces that men can like
see that Pearl my question to you is how
old are you I'm 26. and is it safe to
say most of your friends are in your age
cohort
um
yeah I was just curious
I'm actually my best friend right now is
a 55 year old lady that's beautiful
that's amazing
you said yesterday I'm like all right of
all your friends what's the rate you're
like I have like four friends I know you
know so just to be clear you don't have
a lot of female friends and I recognize
I used to have more when I was younger
but I don't know listen I I and I I
understand why if you're saying things
that call out women and basically you
know shine a light on the negative
things that the negative side of women
and and basically say hey we're attacked
by a woman a lot of women are gonna be
like [ __ ] you yeah so is that one of the
main reasons why you don't have
girlfriends I would say well it's
partially because I moved to England
yeah so it's like I kind of went from
um like being somewhere that I was for a
while and then it's like you're gonna
have an eight-hour time difference from
all year you just kind of lose touch
with people you know all right so the
reason you wanted to yeah I was gonna
say like the newer girls like kind of
saw my podcast and it was fun yeah I'm
good
yeah so it was just like okay so so the
reason why I asked that is because
um when I started my journey like Amber
was like so many guys 20 I was really
came to my like masculinity starting
Journey 19 years old got no girls and I
made no money got no respect and through
years of working on myself improving
literally from the bottom up I was
showing we had a a master class before I
was showing some of my receipts of like
literally being negative 400 in debt
um in my mid-20s and eventually I got to
a point where like I had a good life and
so to me what I realized is eventually
men get to a point when they want to
have a family you know what I mean they
want to build things even yourself like
it's it's cool right but one of the
things that I've noticed is that where
are these Solutions right we've got to
realize that one of the things I love
about AMS I know you said something
about AMS last time but one of the
things like he's a funny guy he just
would talk about [ __ ] These Hoes to
sleep he's changed AMS he's changed my
guy has changed but one of the things I
love about AMS is he would always talk
about a like eventually you guys are
going to grow up from this and
eventually when you're 22 you know at
these girls to sleep XYZ but then you're
gonna want a family if you've never
gotten the tools to build a healthy
family you're going to end up in the
same issues with so many other guys so
what I've noticed as well happen in the
red appeal space is you have these older
guys and unfortunately they've been
divorced but they have their kids so
they can go their own way right but what
about that 22 year old guy who has no
kids who wants to build a family who
wants to learn things and so if my
biggest thing is if we're hell if we're
trying to help men win my desires every
single man should have the best life
possible why are we not giving
information why are we not giving tools
and resources to help those men be
successful so an example of that is when
we talk about divorce and we can go
ahead and get it would you say that game
is resources to help be successful
because they talk about game in like a
relationship like even um Donovan sharp
like he's having a whole so to me I
would I would say traditional game
reminds me a lot of what pickup artist
has which is the game and if you and if
you guys want to do it and do a study
read
um the game by Neil Strauss yeah of
course the first chapter about mystery
about to kill himself it was so powerful
because I cannot tell you how many men
learn how to attract women but never
learn how to retain women they know how
to go on defense they don't know how to
build a family and so my biggest thing
is that if men are never getting the
tools and resources to build a family
what's gonna happen is yeah you'll learn
game but you're a human being you're
gonna actually want to to build a
relationship but if you've never given
those tools to build a healthy
relationship then it will never be able
to last so our desire is that what we
want to focus in on is helping men get
those tools to be able to have healthy
lasting relationships and to have as
many men win as possible that's our
entire goal well and I think that's fine
like you can do that with your channel
but I don't think it's wrong for guys to
have channels that are
more dedicated to exposing female nature
and talking about the negative sides of
marriage too a hundred percent no you're
100 so that's like I I feel like a lot
of men have a good reason for for
avoiding marriage today I love it and
even and even um you could even say even
cohabitation like a woman can seize your
assets even if you're just living
together even so much sense it's in
certain States and I'll say it varies
from state to state I know the chat but
yeah but it's like if she leaves her
stuff at your apartment for like a
period of three months she can literally
seize your assets okay so what what I
what I want to do is I want to go ahead
and address that point so what I truly
believe Adam is a two-folded process and
I had a I had a plan which is why my
content is what it is in two-fold the
process process one is avoid the wrong
woman right process so men need to learn
what does the wrong woman look like and
and given all the tools and knowledge to
avoid the wrong woman but if all you do
is avoid the wrong woman you're gonna
die alone because you'll have no woman
because all you'll be doing is avoiding
women your whole entire life that's
similar like should I say there's no
unicorns no woman's special so so then
the next half is a maturity part of life
where now you have to accept the right
woman and receive the right woman so
reject the wrong receive the right so to
me you have to give those men tools if
if 99 of the content is only about
rejecting the wrong woman and none of
this about receiving the right so one of
the examples I want to give and tell if
you go to the statistics real quick
because my biggest thing is that they
always talk about marriage so you can go
ahead and scroll down you talk about
marriage and the divorce rate right
there what they don't talk about is ways
to lower the divorce rate so you hear
the typical statistics about the divorce
rate 50 XYZ which is not true but they
are a myriad of Statistics that are that
are going about and so here's an
interesting when Natalia pulled up what
people don't realize is the more money
you make the lower the divorce rate is
the divorce rate is is at the highest at
lower income earners and so if a man
going back to making money one of the
things I think the right people teach
they don't realize that actually earning
more money increase marital stability
another thing if you go back to the data
Natalia is that if you look up um
um
can I finish and then you can go and ask
your question so another thing that's
also discussed is about religious
couples because there's a misnomer in
actuality if you look at the ifs studies
religious couples have a 47 percent
lower divorce rate there's so many
different things that you can do to
drastically lower the divorce rate it's
never going to be zero nothing is going
to be zero in this life but there are so
many things that every single man can do
today to drastically lower the divorce
rate to give him the best chance of
raising his family and so is my desire
is let's give give them to let them know
the bad but let's give all the give the
men all the tools to win and have the
best life possible that's all that
matters to me men winning well um my
question was what is religious how do
you define someone being religious great
question on Pearl so Pastor Mark
Driscoll in his book Real Marriage
talked about this I would advise people
to read the book because I'm a secondary
source talking about a primary source
because what people confuse and I don't
want to get too much into religion
because people hate when I do that but
what people confuse about the religion
is it's not so much saying that you're
religious it's practicing religion so
going back to the data Natalia thing was
even deeper than religion is political
and cultural differences so you click on
that data so political so what um Dr Rob
Henderson recently shared with me is is
that one of the biggest correlations
that lead that lower divorce is your
political affiliation so for example if
if you're a hard right Maga guy and
you're dating this blue-haired feminist
who's a liberal who you know who
believes in aoc's being a champion of
the world is going to lead into divorce
so what's your extreme example I don't
think those two are getting together but
if they are that they are so what
happens is is similar values so that's
what the religious things is so there's
so many things I can I want the guys to
look up the data themselves it's all
about man looking up the data themselves
but all these things help lower the
divorce rate and help men win these are
the tools that I want to give to men I
want to see as much men have best life
as possible yeah I want to address one
thing that you said that I think is very
important for men to understand because
especially for your younger as out there
you talked about the most important
decision a man can ever make as many of
you know know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible